字幕提供
上上次在理財丹秀說建設
隔天朋友進場一路套到上週四
這裡啊 我在這邊說
他進場 那隔天是有開高嗎
那開高就一路套
然後就怪我
拜託欸 我們在這邊講對不對
然後呢 你在這天裡
無論如何 任何一個
除非你追漲停嘛 任何一個時間點買
這邊都會賺錢嘛
然後重點在這一天怎麼樣
這一天我們還有特別講喔
在這一天呢
它見測呢 它又會被關
有一個被關條件
所以呢 只要它被關
我們就會怎麼樣 先賣掉
那這種被關的呢 我們做了APP
讓你可以去查
你都知道說我們這些教學的策略
難道我在這邊錄影完
那講完之後 我們還要講說
欸 未來齁 各位記得
明天 因為我哪知道隔天會漲停啊
那隔天會漲停 它就會
也會影響到隔天聽牌的條件嘛
他那个听牌条件是每天在变动的
所以我没办法一下子就预言到
再隔天再隔隔天
他的听牌条件怎么样
也没办法把你的这个进出场的
那个SOP也讲得很清楚
因为我根本不晓得股票会涨到哪里嘛
那假设建策
他在这一天是大涨的话
他就不会被关
不会被关就不用卖掉嘛
有些细节
其实你必须要自己去研究
你不是听了别人讲之后
那你买
有买
赚钱
赚钱都自己的事
然后只要一赔都别害的
这个逻辑呢其实我们都有讲清楚那我们都是提早讲提早做只是我没办法每天去电视上面跟你讲啊我不可能每天去理财团就录影嘛想每天看到我的
你就PP上面看嘛
PP每天都会看到我
甚至你可以问问题
问说这个股票被关的条件怎么样
这你都可以问嘛
那这种被关条件呢
我们也会教你
你怎么用主持神器看
主持神器也可以看啊
我们是不只教你方法
還設計了工具給你
我只差不能當一個投稿老師
然後每天跟你講說
幾塊買進幾塊賣數而已
因為我假如當投稿老師
我跟各位講我當投稿老師是
國家的損失喔為什麼國家的損失
欸
我每個月繳稅就幾百萬了
每年的交易證交稅都上千萬
我每年交那麼多證交稅
我一當投稿老師我就不用交這些證交稅了
我就沒辦法打單了嘛
對不對我每天打那麼多單
每天有一堆交易赚钱的方法
那我们是实际做
那觉得好做
分享给各位
就像那个小秘书跟我讲
小哥最近要不要开一下放空实战班
我说最近不要开
因为最近放空特难做
所以最近不要开放空实战班
我们都会想说最近什么方法比较好做
就教你什么方法
那为什么我知道什么方法比较好做
很简单吧
因为我们很多策略
然后呢
这策略呢一定有比较赚钱的
有比较最近不好赚的
那我们就是把比较好赚的跟你讲嘛
那比较不好做的
自己做不好做我们就不会跟你讲了
最近这个策略不好做
所以呢
我们是用实战呢来
过我们的每一天
好不好
实战过每一天我们就有很多交易心得嘛
然后又付了很多交易税嘛
这种实战的心得呢是最宝贵的